[Music]
here's a standard bait bag Bob singing
you need to stop moping dude I can't go
home for Christmas either hurt my mom
poor thing your mom should've heard my
mom why why do you guys have to go on
such poorly timed work trips she was a
wreck
oh she was huh interesting interesting
interesting Christmas isn't the same
without the holiday traditions you know
holiday traditions just okay I'm gonna
let it slide because I know you're upset
I don't know cheer you up
I know exactly what'll cheer you up but
cheers me up all the time there you go
yeah come on it's fun right oh just
sitting here yeah it's a blast oh you're
not watching here watch that kid right
there watch him go going going going
there he goes there he goes hee hee
who's that coming I did a sock that I
knew was gonna happen there alcohol in
this it's a Lost Boys Christmas Garrett
there are no rules that's the case
[Music]
I'm gonna go drink after this no I still
have community service still you are not
the father
hahahaha how many more hours you gotta
that thirty-six halfway there man I
never looked so cool my entire skip it
hey hey guys hey Alex
what do you what are you two doing uh
well actually we're going home to make
cookies for Santa gotta see if we can
get him stoned and then he'll drop all
of his presence must be must be nice not
uh not being alone on Christmas Eve I
could use a buddy to do his work I've
just been taping all them together alone
crying look at his eyes these had death
behind those eyes look at it he's weird
Garrett come on I feel bad he's gonna be
alone on Christmas desert city nobody
deserves to be alone on Christmas yeah
well you could celebrate with us then
you mean that should we wait for him he
knows where we live okay
well greatest eggnog
[Music]
hey mom how's Miami wait what yeah you
know now I'll be there in like Toni all
right yes season yo my parents flight
got canceled I guess I go home for the
night oh yeah yeah that's great yeah
have fun I said yes see you guys later
yeah okay okay have fun Merry Christmas
bye Merry Christmas yeah you don't have
to keep writing by that tree I know
you're there oh yeah we sorry okay
creature of habit
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Merry Christmas jerk you're back what
did you get back last night you're
asleep so wait did you eat all those
cookies scared they had a lot of weed in
them dude I don't know if they were
actually safe to consume
no I didn't I thought you ate them
[Music]
you don't think yes it yeah
are you freaking kidding me oh my god
it's a Christmas miracle May Christmas
fell it's so hot